un petit déjeuner sain un corps sain et
une planète saine vendredi 26 mars des
élèves de 5e du collège paul bert de
chatou ont participé à un parcours
éducatif de santé qui allie plusieurs
disciplines
l'anglais les svt la physique-chimie et
le sport et la matinée a commencé par un
petit déjeuner équilibré
aujourd'hui j'ai pris un peu en chocolat
un kiwi bio du jus de pomme bio de la
pâte à tartiner bio avec des crêpes
les crêpes au cias mondiaux du lait au
chocolat chaque élève a pu composer son
petit déjeuner pour avoir un aliment il
fallait le demander en anglais et les
collégiens ont bien compris qu'on
pouvait se faire plaisir en mangeant
équilibré et en respectant la planète
là je trouve que c'est bien comme ça ça
nous apprend à bien manger et à prendre
le temps de bien choisir ses aliments et
de bien manger parce que c'est important
pour la santé
la rectrice de l'académie de versailles
a rencontré les collégiens ils ont
présenté des expériences de physique
chimie et ont fait goûter une pâte à
tartiner maison la matinée s'est conclue
par du sport ont fait faire un parcours
qui a été construit avec des médecins
dans une salle de sport donc il ya des
tests de force des tests d'endurance des
tests respiratoires et cela permet de
faire prendre conscience aux jeunes de
l'importance de toutes ces données
ces exercices de sport permettent entre
autres de repérer les élèves en
difficulté surtout les tests que nous
avons fait est à peu près 25% de jeunes
qui ont besoin de redynamiser leurs
activités de santé et pour lesquels il
faut qu'on fasse le lien avec
l'infirmière l'enseignant de ps qui va
pouvoir apporter des réponses plus
personnalisé aux résultats de ce test
la caravane santé de l'ue nss versailles
a été lancée à la rentrée 2020 il ya
déjà touché 5000 élèves dans l'académie